[Music]
from asteroids capable of destroying
entire species to gamma-ray bursts and
supernovae that could exterminate life
on Earth outer space has no shortage of
forces that could wreak havoc on our
tiny planet but there's something in
space that seems more terrifying than
any of these something that wipes out
everything it comes near could the earth
be swallowed by a black hole a black
hole is an object so dense that space
and time around it are inescapably
modified warped into an infinite sink
nothing not even light can move fast
enough to escape a black hole's
gravitational pull once it passes a
certain boundary known as the event
horizon thus a black hole is like a
cosmic vacuum cleaner with infinite
capacity gobbling up everything in its
path and letting nothing out to
determine whether a black hole could
swallow the earth we first have to
figure out where they are
but since they don't emit light how's
that possible fortunately we're able to
observe their effect on the space around
them when matter approaches a black hole
the immense gravitational field
accelerates it to high speed this emits
an enormous amount of light and for
objects too far away to be sucked in the
massive gravitational force still
affects their orbits if we observe
several stars orbiting around an
apparently empty point a black hole
could be leading the dance
similarly light that passes close enough
to an event horizon will be deflected in
a phenomenon known as gravitational
lensing most of the black holes that
we've found can be thought of as two
main types the smaller ones called
stellar-mass black holes have a mass
upto 100 times larger than that of our
Sun they're formed when a massive star
consumes all its nuclear fuel
and its core collapses we've observed
several of these objects as close as
3,000 light years away and there could
be up to 100 million small black holes
just in the Milky Way galaxy so should
we be worried probably not despite their
large mass stellar black holes only have
a radius of around 300 kilometers or
less making the chances of a direct hit
with us minuscule although because their
gravitational fields can affect a planet
from a large distance they could be
dangerous even without a direct
collision if a typical stellar-mass
black hole were to pass in the region of
Neptune the orbit of the earth would be
considerably modified with dire results
still the combination of how small they
are and how vast the galaxy is means
that stellar black holes don't give us
much to worry about but we still have to
meet the second type supermassive black
holes these have masses millions or
billions times greater than that of our
Sun and have event horizons that could
span billions of kilometers these giants
have grown to immense proportions by
swallowing matter and merging with other
black holes unlike their stellar cousins
supermassive black holes aren't
wandering through space instead they lie
at the center of galaxies including our
own our solar system is in a stable
orbit around a supermassive black hole
that resides at the center of the Milky
Way at a safe distance of 25,000 light
years but that could change if our
galaxy collides with another the earth
could be thrown towards the galactic
center close enough to the supermassive
black hole to be eventually swallowed up
in fact a collision with the Andromeda
galaxy is predicted to happen four
billion years from now which may not be
great news for our home planet but
before we judge them too harshly black
holes are simply agents of destruction
they played a crucial role in the
formation of galaxies the building
blocks of our universe far from being a
shadowy characters in the cosmic play
black holes have fundamentally
contributed in making the universe a
bright and astonishing place for a
fast-paced freewheeling tour of life the
universe and everything
we highly recommend New York Times
bestseller The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy you can download an audio version
of the book narrated by the inimitable
Stephen Fry for free at audible.com
long and thanks for all the fish
[Music]